Ich habe in der letzten Zeit vermehrten Bauchschmerzen und Übelkeit.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit vier bis fünf Wochen jetzt schon. Aber heute ist besonders schlimm.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Klaus Peter.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Wie wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 90 Kilogramm.
90.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ein Meter 72.
Wie heißen Sie Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Herr Vogel, Dr. Vogel.
Haben Sie Überweisung oder?
Ich bin selber gekommen heute.
Sie haben seit drei Wochen Bauchschmerzen und Übelkeit.
Ja, vier bis fünf Wochen Bauchschmerzen und Übelkeit.
Aber heute ist sehr schlimm geworden.
Die Nacht war sehr schlimm.
Könnten Sie bitte mir sagen, wo Ihr Schmerzen ist?
Im Oberbau habe ich die Beschwerden.
Oberbau?
Linke Seite oder reite Seite oder Mitte?
Mitte, ja, Mitte.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen aus?
Irgendwo aus?
Nein, sie sind sehr stark lokalisiert im Mittelbau.
Im Mittelbau?
Also mittlerer Oberbau.
Sie haben Überweisung oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, ich habe noch nicht.
Morgen habe ich sehr heftige Überweisung.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, diese Schmerzen nach dem Essen oder vor dem Essen zu haben?
Soviel als auch beides.
Beides, okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen bewegungsabhängig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Haben Sie gemessen oder fühlen Sie sich febrig?
Ich fühle mich nicht febrig, aber ich denke nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Ich habe selber nicht gemessen.
Okay, haben Sie Durchfall, haben Sie Probleme mit Stullgang?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Müssen Sie auch stossen?
Ja.
Könnten Sie bitte mir beschreiben, wie diese Schmerzen sind?
Das sind so stechende Schmerzen.
Manchmal auch krampfartig, manchmal auch drückend.
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Drückend krampfartig?
Kommende und gehende, manchmal?
Ja, manchmal dauert es auch sehr lange.
Manchmal dauert es über mehrere Minuten.
Aber ich habe es eigentlich immer.
Okay, immer.
Ja, manchmal ist es brennend, manchmal ist es nur drückend, manchmal stechend, manchmal ziehend, sehr unterschiedlich.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie Husten oder Auswurfen haben?
Ich habe keine Husten, ich habe auch keine Auswurfe.
Okay, und haben Sie Schmerzen?
In den letzten 2 Tagen, ja, weil ich Schmerzen habe, ansonsten habe ich keine Probleme.
Wer kann Schmerzen?
Richtig.
Okay, haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit oder gegen etwas Unverträglichkeit?
Ich habe eigentlich keine Appetitlosigkeit.
Und haben Sie Gewicht ab, haben Sie, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, in der letzter Zeit Gewicht abnehmen zu haben?
Ich habe 2 bis 3 kg verloren, ja.
Wie lange?
In den letzten 4 Wochen ungefähr.
Ich glaube, das war nicht zu wenig gegessen, oder weniger Essen wegen Schmerzen.
Warum essen Sie weniger?
Weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Ja, wegen Schmerzen.
Ich denke schon, ja.
Und haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich haue nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten, nur am Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie?
Wein, Bier, Schnaps.
Ja, beide.
Schnaps auch, ne?
Selten, ja, Bier und Wein.
Wie viel trinken Sie am Wochenende?
Kommt immer noch wann.
Halben Kasten bestimmt Bier, ein bisschen Aglisavine.
So unterschiedlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen oder Anderen?
Wie meinen Sie Kontakt?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Komm ich jetzt Verkauf oder was?
Nein, nein.
Nehmen Sie zum Beispiel, brauchen Sie Cannabis oder Anderen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und ich möchte gerne wissen, ob Sie Vorerkrankungen haben.
Ich habe Blutdruck und Nebengrockenkohlesthröne ein.
Und haben Sie Blutdruckkrankheit?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme ein Blutdruck Medikamente ein morgens und abends.
Und ich nehme eine kolesterolin Tablette abends vor den Schlaf.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie nah?
Einmal El Misatán und einmal Atomastatin.
Wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ich bin jetzt kurz operiert worden.
Vorher generell, ja.
Bin ich darm operiert oder?
Meine Mandeln sind nur gern worden.
Und wenn?
Das ist schon lange.
Da war ich noch ein Kind.
Okay.
Und sind Ihre Eltern leben?
Leben Ihre Eltern?
Beide sind verstorben.
Darf ich fragen, warum Ihre Eltern...
Verkehrsunfall.
Es tut mir leid.
Hatten Ihre Eltern chronische Krankheit?
Zum Beispiel Karzinom oder Blutdruck?
Ja, meine Mutter und Vater haben beide Blutdruck.
Genau wie ich.
Ich würde gerne über Ihre Hauptbeschwerden widersprechen.
Und wie ich diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10...
7 umgezählt.
Sieben?
Nein, manche auch 5.
Aber diese Nacht war schon bei 7.
Gleich sogar bei 8.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt heute hier.
Haben Sie dafür etwas eingenommen?
Ein Medikament oder Schmerzmittel?
Ich habe in der Apotheke etwas bekommen.
Lutsch-Tabletten habe ich bekommen.
Kautabletten haben etwas geholfen.
Das hat die Apothekerin gegeben.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Kautabletten bekommen.
Kaun-Tabletten.
Und die haben so eine halbe Stunde bis eine Stunde geholfen.
Dann kommen die Zündungen wieder.
Okay.
Haben Sie 40-Jährige Luft?
Oder bei Belastung haben Sie Luftnot?
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasalas?
Haben Sie Probleme mit Sturbank, Zumba, Stopfunk?
Oder Volleggefühl?
Nein, ich habe nur für mehr Aufstoßen in der letzten Zeit.
Aber Sturrgangsprobleme habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Durukgefühl hinter den Brustbein?
Nein, Brustschmerzen nicht.
Im Unterenbau.
Oberbau.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben zwei Töchter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Töchter?
Ja.
Haben Sie Stress in der letzten Zeit?
Ob ich Stress habe?
Ich habe eigentlich immer Stress.
Ja, wegen der Arbeit?
Ja.
Ein Moment kurz bitte.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme?
Ich habe einige Probleme.
Schluckprobleme habe ich nicht.
Schweißausbrücke?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Ich bin fertig.
Ich habe notwendige Fragen.
Ich würde gerne Sie untersuchen.
Danach habe ich Blutabnehmen.
Ich werde Blutabnehmen.
Vielleicht führe ich Ultraschall durch.
Ich werde mit meinem Chefarzt sprechen.
Danach werde ich Ihnen informieren.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Petra.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verzerrt oder nicht?
Wenn ich esse, sind die Schmerzen mehr.
Okay, danke.
Sind Sie schon einmal einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich war noch nicht bei einem anderen Arzt.
Nein.
Haben Sie?
Kann ich fragen?
Nein, keine Fragen.
Haben Sie früher eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Zum ersten Mal habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lkw-Fahrer.
Haben Sie eine Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Waren Sie in der Stadion im Ausland?
Beruflich.
Ich bin Lkw-Fahrer.
Ich fahre immer nach Holland, Belgien, Luxemburg.
Herr Petra, sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Es wird jetzt zunehmend.
Ich habe das schon seit vier bis fünf Wochen.
Aber es wird immer schlimmer.
Trotz dieser Cout-Tabletten von der Apotheken-Nähme.
Es wird immer schlimmer.
Kennen Sie den genauen Namen von dieser Cout-Tabletten?
Hab ich vergessen, aber irgendwas mit Parallel.
Könnten wir als Erzhaßgäste anfangen?
Ja, ich versuche.
Ich hoffe, dass es...
Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patent aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen, ob Sie dafür seid.
Ja, bedüßt mich.
Es geht um Klaus Petra.
Herr Petra ist 50 Jahre alt.
Herr Petra wiegt 90 Kilogramm.
Er ist 1,72 Meter groß.
Der Hausarzt des Patentens heißt Örvogel.
Die Vorstellung des Patentens erfolgt in unserem Praxis
seit vier bis fünf Wochen bestehende
Jahre.
Er klagt über...
Und ich untersuche Oberbau mit Oberbau.
Die Auskultation ist wichtig.
Und ich werde auskultieren, palpieren.
Nehmen Sie die Lüter?
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Oberbauschmerzen bei den Männern kann Corona-Sendern sein.
Deswegen werde ich EKG schreiben.
Und inferior Mijakartinfarktis kommt manchmal mit Oberbauschmerzen, besonders bei den Männern.
Und ich füge Bauchutraschall durch.
Und ÖGD füge ich durch.
Was füllen Sie durch?
ÖGD.
Nehmen Sie die Ambulanz oder die Station?
Nehmen Sie die Station auf?
Ja.
Ja, ich kann die Prothongpompa vergeben.
Intervenus?
Ja, Infondieren.
Antiasitis-Tableten kann ich geben.
Wenn Sie machen müssen, aber nicht im Krankenhaus, macht man das nicht so oft.
Wir haben Pontoprazol, das können wir geben.
Und wenn Ihnen das hilft, ist das gut.
Und dann versuchen Sie zeitnah eine ÖGD zu machen.
Ja.
Und ÖGD bedeutet was?
ÖGD.
Und dann sehen Sie ein Ulcus zum Beispiel.
Ich muss eine Infektion wegen Helicobacter bestätigen.
Oder auch Malignum vielleicht?
Ja, Malignum, Formagenkart.
Kann auch sein.
Wenn es ein Ulcus, wenn es Tricolier ist.
Es ist selten, dass man eine Katzenum hat.
Ulcus, wenn es Tricolier ist, ist es sehr aufregend.
Ja.
Gut.
Und wenn Sie jetzt Helicobacter sehen, was machen Sie dann?
Am 2. Tag später?
Ja, dann...
Sie können auch einen Steltest machen.
Steltest gibt es auch.
Ich soll Patrianten einige Medikamente einnehmen.
Das ist Bismuth.
Und...
Erhridikation Therapie.
Genau.
Helicobactereridikation Therapie.
Metronidazol, Bismuth.
Glörthromisin und Protopompehema.
Sehr gut.
Das hört sich gut an.
Bismuth Therapie,
Tetrazyklin, Metronidazol.
Und Protonpompenimetronen.
Okay.
Tetrazyklin, oder?
Bismuth, Tetrazyklin und...
Metronidazol.
Protonpompenimetronen, PPI.
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Man sollte gucken, wenn man jetzt ein Ulcus Ventricoli hat,
und das ein großer Ulcus ist,
sollte man nach Beendigung oder der Therapie
nach 4 bis 8 Wochen nochmal schauen,
ob das Ulcus abgeheilt ist.
Also eine zweite ÖGD machen.
Muslime oder...
Sollte man, ja.
Warum?
Um zu gucken, ob man irgendwelche Karzinomen übersehen hat.
Also ob es doch ein Karzinom sein könnte.
Aber erst die Biopsy,
haben wir entnehmen und Labor...
Ja, vielleicht hat man es aber verpasst.
Vielleicht hat man falsche genommen, die Biopsy zum Beispiel.
Man muss sich sicher gehen,
dass unter der PPI Therapie das Ulcus weniger wird.
Also abheilt.
Okay.
Habt ihr Kollegen noch Fragen?
Herr Kollege, eine Frage.
Wenn wir den Patienten das erste Mal den Oberarzt vorstellen,
wäre es dann korrekt, zum Beispiel,
es geht um,
um einen Punkt zu verwenden oder?
Ja.
Guten Tag Herr Bündnis.
Es geht um Herrn Peter Helgut.
Aber Sie sind Oberarzt
und diese Patienten erst mal sehen,
aber nicht stetönär.
Vorherrigen nicht gesehen haben.
Ja, aber Sie müssen nicht unbedingt einen Namen nennen.
Sie können auch sagen, es geht um eine 68-jährige Patientin,
die in der Notaufnahme ist.
Sie müssen nicht unbedingt einen Namen nennen.
Muss man nicht machen, aber Sie können, das ist gut.
Es geht um Herrn Gündnis, der 58 Jahre alt ist,
hat sich heute erst mal nicht in eine Ambulanz vorgestellt,
mit zunehmenden anhaltenden Epigastralgien.
Zum Beispiel.
Wenn er auf Station ist,
natürlich, dann weiß der Oberarzt das.
Es geht um Herrn Gündnis auf Station 11,
mit dem Verdacht auf eine Gastrittis.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Ich kann alle Fragen stellen, wie Sie möchten.
Ganz einfacher Fall.
PPI-Test.
Könntest du wieder erklären, Magian?
PPI-Test?
Ja, dann kann man eine Biopsy entnehmen,
in so einem Glas rein tun,
dann wechselt das die Farbe.
Ganz einfaches.
Nichts Wildes.
Atemtest macht man nicht mehr.
Atemtest oder so was.
Man macht eher bei Hausarzt,
macht eher bei Hausarzt,
macht Stuhlantigentest zum Beispiel.
Aber in der ÖGD
kann man einen Schnelltest-Oriase-Test machen.
Die Behandlung von der Rallikation dauert 10 Tage.
10 Tage.
4 mal 3 Tabletten einnehmen.
Einmal oder?
Einmal.
Wenn immer noch nicht besser ist,
dann muss man 2-Lingentherapie machen.
Nach Resistenztestung.
Man muss eine Resistenztestung machen.
Resistenztestung.
Man muss das wegschicken
und dann Antibiotker Resistenztest machen.
Und dann die Helikobacter-Testung.
Okay.
Vorher haben wir die Kreitzung geschrieben.
Jetzt.
Kleidromissen.
Nein, es gibt es.
Erstlingentherapie ist Quadruppeltherapie.
Früher hat man Erstlingentherapie gehabt von Sösisch
oder Italienisch.
Man hat gehabt zum Beispiel
Kleidromizin, Amoxicillin und PPI.
Oder man hat gehabt Kleidromizin,
Metronidazole, PPI.
Das ist jetzt 2-Lingentherapie.
Erstlingentherapie ist Bismut.
Plus Tentrazycline.
Plus Metronidazole.
Plus PPI.
Das Medikament heißt in Deutschland Pylera.
Pylera.
P Y L E R A.
120 Tabletten.
120.
Mit Bismut, Tentrazycline, Metronidazole und PPI.
Plus PPI.
4x 3 Tabletten. Also 12 Tabletten am Tag.
Okay.
Gut. Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ganz einfache Frage. Typische Frage.
Nichts.